brian scalarini the white mamba celtics
analyst for nbcsn
and co-host of scowl and powell's daily
podcast
joining us on the program after the
celtics go up two games to none
on the raptors surprised brian
yeah actually i really am i thought the
uh i thought
the backcourt of the celtics you think
about brown tatum
walker i thought those guys would have a
good series i thought they would be a
lot better than the toronto backcourt
but i
really thought that serge ibaka mark
gasol former defensive player of the
year
these guys are champions i didn't think
that they would be outplayed by robert
williams and daniel tice or
even grant williams for for that matter
and the celtic bigs have really done a
great job and marcus smart really won
that game
his contributions offensively are always
a bonus in boston and he's shooting the
ball like that man it's a long it's
gonna be a long series for toronto
what about gordon hayward's availability
yeah i don't think he's gonna play this
series dan
i think uh the best guess is for him to
play into the eastern conference finals
there's also another caveat to this i
think his wife is having a baby
she's due around mid-september so even
if he
was to get back you know the bubble is a
really interesting place because you
don't just
walk on campus and all of a sudden be
cleared to play there's quarantine and
stuff like that he would have to leave
for the birth of his son and then have
to get back and do the whole quarantine
all over again so
i'm not sure he'll be in the series i i
think for the celtics is looking forward
moving forward to if they get past
toronto in the eastern conference finals
we brought this up a couple of weeks ago
and i said if you're looking at the
young
tandems in the nba and you look at tatum
and brown in boston
you look at luca and kristops in dallas
i don't know if there's another one that
comes behind we talked about embiid and
simmons in philadelphia
but if you were going to pick the best
tandem out of those three
those three teams
you know i i think i would go with you
i really like luca i think he's going to
be an all-time great player i just don't
think that porzingis with the injury
history is good enough
so i think i would take the versatile
wings of boston because
no matter who you put around them those
guys can defend
multiple positions jalen brown can guard
a one through four
jayson tatum with his size and strength
and guard at one through four
so it would be easier to build a team
off of having
two versatile wings that could shoot the
ball score it and defend their position
so
i would i would go that direction one
one uh
interesting caveat with this would be
giannis
and d vincenzo i don't know giannis is
such a dominant force no no no
dante divincenzo no
i just had to throw someone in there
that was young you know
but with giannis is such a dynamic
player that and he's so young as well
but no i think i think
the the boston it would be the easiest
team to build around if you had
jason tatum and jaylen brown the easiest
way to build a championship team because
you could add
pretty much a lot of different pizzas to
that and those guys would fit in
how long were you uh on the celtics with
paul pierce
five years when did you start to
understand
or realize that he really hated lebron
james are there there was a real issue
between those two
yeah i think um so when i got there we
weren't good the first two years
and i think as soon as kevin garnett got
there it became
and we don't get this a lot in today's
nba it became us against the world
mentality
like you're either with us or we hate
you you know like and so
i think that's when this whole thing
started and
i i feel like pierce was was having
garnett behind him
it made it a a much different fight when
you're fighting going against lebron
before that i mean it wasn't this we
just weren't very good i mean you it was
hard to have that
rivalry with lebron if you're not
matching up in the playoffs but paul
still has a problem with lebron
that's old-school generation you know
how that is i mean michael jordan still
has a problem with isaiah thomas so
it's just the way it was back then no
one's hugging it out yeah but lebron
didn't do anything to paul pierce except
for beat him
um yeah i guess you're right i can't
think of anything in particular i mean
isaiah may have kept
or you know mike and isaiah they had
that feud go you know for they beat him
up
uh and then mike says i don't want you
on the dream team i'm gonna i mean
that's that's deep stuff
i don't know if paul pierce and lebron
ever had a moment where
because it really bothers lebron he
won't even acknowledge lebron i think
uh paul doesn't acknowledge him as what
a top five player of all time
yeah i guess you're right it does
i think paul's a good analyst that does
seem a little sour grapes
maybe there's the ray allen element to
it i don't know but
you're right about that dan because even
like magic and bird as much as they
disliked each other early
they were all they were cool with each
other and now as retired players
i know lebron is still playing but piers
is past that you would think that
they would be all good with it and piers
would recognize you know the duel or
you know how great lebron is but that's
a good that's a good point by you
but what happened with ray allen was it
just because he went to the enemy and he
went
yeah he joined lebron and that was it
yeah
i mean dan you know how the old you know
how the old school guys are man
but well first of all another thing
about the nba back in the day was
people found reasons to hate other
people it wasn't the opposite where they
i guess they inherently like him to
begin with and then they find reasons to
hate him
like initially you just found reasons to
create
you know i guess drama or controversy
but you knew the best at that as you saw
in the last dance
michael jordan oh he he looked for
different random reasons of why
he can end up hating somebody and
insignificant people at times but
that's the old school way i think
garnett was like that pierce was like
that
geez i i kendrick perkins is like that
there's a lot of guys that are that are
like that
he's brian scalabrine the white mamba
the celtics analyst for nbcsn boston
did you ever talk to kobe since he was
the original
mamba the black mom but did he was he
okay with you being the white
mamba yeah so he he sort of quote
unquote endorsed me on twitter
and that was it so i like he came out on
social media i followed like a week
later
kind of with a pun tweet like he said
the anti-social
go social i said this mambo waited
longer than that mamba
and he he hit he hit me with uh welcome
to twitter white mamba
and i went from like dan i went from 4
000 followers to 80 000 followers
in like four hours i i couldn't believe
it so
uh and then on the last game you know
we uh had it at a cool little moment
where you know like
we did the whole shake and pound and
we went on our merry way unspoken hug
bro hug did you but you never got
isolated on him did you like did you
guard you yeah actually
actually i always bring this up because
if you
when you can prepare for nba players you
can watch their last 50 clips you can
just ask the film guy and they'll
deliver it for you right and it was
amazing every most guys they do about
five to seven things
most people you know and it's there's
all about the same move
i watched kobe's last 50 makes and
i think it was 45 different shots and
then i told the film guy
i need another 50 makes and i think it
was another like
40 different shot then we got in the
game i guarded him
and i think he went left one foot runner
and of his
last hundred makes i didn't see that
shot taken at once he just had such an
arsenal of different ways to beat you i
think he was
probably the greatest shot creator or
tough shot maker to ever play this game
but how often are guys watching film oh
a
lot
regularly it's so easy dan it's like uh
for two for you to watch a guy's last
hundred makes it takes around 15 minutes
it's amazing what you can learn in 15
minutes when it's cut up for you
not when you have to watch an entire
game and kobe would take 25 shots in
that game no i'm talking about
you can get the last two or three weeks
a matter of
it's really easy to prepare that way but
do players have
tells like a pitcher can sometimes you
know they can be telling you what the
pitch is without even knowing
yeah absolutely i mean remember a great
scorer tracy mcgrady
tracy mcgrady had about three or four
things that he did and they all sort of
set up the same way and it was amazing
when you study it and you see it and
you're in the game how much everything
sort of slows down
but you couldn't stop him no no no you
couldn't stop
him but you could get back into his
airspace a little bit quicker listen dan
i wasn't going to stop anybody anyways
they just gave me a better chance of
stopping him
what was your your proudest defensive
moment
uh nba finals lamar odom he's destroyed
us at every end of quarter
in 2010 and doc rivers i haven't played
in like two months stock rivers for
whatever reason put me in the game
and uh i i had to pick him up full court
i turned him a couple times i made him
like semi turn it over and we gotta stop
and he
had destroyed us at the end of quarters
it was rasheed garnett big baby
whoever was out there he has got to the
basket and that was probably like my
greatest defensive stop in
obviously game seven of the nba finals
if the rockets lose tonight
wow you know what's funny is um
they gave up so much to get russell
westbrook
and they gave up chris paul and chris
paul has been
unbelievable for oklahoma city they got
assets oklahoma city did and
they go all in on these on this duo
and if it doesn't work i don't i don't
know what happens to d'antonio i don't
know what happens to daryl mori i don't
know what happens to the rockets
remember their owner tillman fertitta
he's in the restaurant business as you
know right now that restaurant business
is not doing well so
i think a lot of things are come into
play
based off the outcome of this game yeah
i wonder
it feels like mike d'antoni is coaching
for his job tonight
i think it's i'm not sure i'm not sure
he wants to be there dan i'm not sure
i think it might be a two-way street i'm
not sure it's one it's a one-way street
where the guys don't want him back
i'm not sure he wants to be there why i
don't know because when they offered him
the five million dollar extension he
just turned it down he said like no way
like no problem
plus there's been links to him being in
indiana and they got rid of nate
mcmillan and right away the name you
hear is mike d'antoni
maybe he just wants to change change the
scenery you know in coaching
it's not always like it's always like oh
this is a bad coach this is a good coach
sometimes
timing comes into play sometimes your
voice grows stale
and you just need a new guy to come in
no disrespect to that coach or
and then and the next coach coming in
might not even be as good of a coach as
mike d'antoni
but it could work because it's new and
it's fresh and i think that happens a
lot in the nba
how often do doc rivers yell at you in
boston uh me
personally yeah oh not not on the
not on the championship years i was like
the 13th man the 12th man
it was more about you know i'll tell you
one thing doc did every year
is he would sit the team down somewhere
five or seven games into the season
and establish everyone's role your role
is this your role is this
kevin garnett we need more from you ray
allen you need to do this paul pierce
you need to do that and
i've never seen a coach or been a part
of a coach coaching staff
that just was so direct like that and
calling guys out and saying this is what
we need from you
and we all need to sacrifice and that
team and he doc has the
biggest pulse on his team more than any
coach i've ever
been a part of he understands what
players are thinking during the course
of an 82 game season or a playoff run or
whatever it is
well what was your role did he did he
say and brian i need
no just catch and shoot like he would
make it simple and then he'd move on to
the next guy so it wasn't like
it wasn't it wasn't i i think it was
more about
telling you know dan there's a lot of
money at stake with nba players
and to tell a player you're not going to
do x y and z we only want you to do one
thing
you're you know you're getting that
player to sacrifice you know the greater
good of his own financial
rewards and uh to get a guy to do that
and to have you run through a wall
for a guy that's asking you to make
sacrifices that's not an easy thing to
do so you made sacrifices that
no for the betterment i was just happy
to be there
i was just happy to be there yeah and
garnett would always
he was such a great trash talker wasn't
he him and peers together
were the greatest duo of trash talkers
they would play off each other
they would have ever be like if me and
you were talking
and we were talking about a guy who was
sitting like you know
two feet away and we were talking about
how like that person shouldn't even be
here right now
i don't know why he's on the show how
does he have a job how does he make it
in this world
like what were your parents like he me
and you communicating about this guy
and and it took sometimes it took some
nba players a while to realize like wait
a minute they're talking about right
well tim duncan would always tell me
that garnett tried to get in his head
and and it and tim drove him crazy
because tim wouldn't allow kevin garnett
to get into his head
correct and and uh i'll tell you another
guy dirk nowitzki
he would never back down from garnett
and i would it was uh
that i i liked how like a lot of players
would melt
and dirk would bring it uh his level up
when garnett would start trash talking
to dirk what would he say to dirk
i don't know what they were when they
were guarding each other what was being
said but i know
like dirk dirk was about that life he
was
he liked the the challenges of you know
the 82 game grind
kevin garnett comes in and you know it's
not just a normal game on a wednesday
night like he
kevin garnett made the level higher and
dirk
it woke dirk up saying like all right
i'm about to stand i will say this
early dirk was very different like once
he lost to the warriors
i think he became a different guy and he
was like very tough to stop
very mentally tough very uh he
he wanted the smoke as we would say in
the nba he was about that
good to visit with you brian uh
appreciate you joining us hope you're
well
you got it too uh be safe dan see you
that's brian scalabrine
celtics analyst for nbcsn in boston and
uh the white mambas got a podcast called
scowl and pals